We've talked about potential places
where your app can really shine and
where it can really fail.
Being on the development team of an app
can lead to a certain type of blindness.
You know the app so
well that you naturally miss some of the
pain points a new user might run into.
This is where bringing in external
feedback can be extremely helpful.
As soon as you publish your app, or even
beforehand, when showing it to testers,
you get a flood of advice.
This feedback can be a great
source of new perspectives and
give you insight into exactly how
people are using your app, or
even better,
how they want to use your app.
Having a large,
diverse set of users can be one of
the keys to building a successful app.
Remember, that while feedback from
others who have built Android
apps can be helpful, it shouldn't
be your only source of feedback.